Plus de la moitié des femmes souffrent en silence d'un trouble sexuel.
Nous entendons plus parler de l'inégalité face à l'orgasme.
C'est comme l'inégalité salariale mais en plus collant...
(Rires)
Les femmes hétérosexuelles atteignent l'orgasme
dans moins de 60% de leurs rapports sexuels.
Les hommes atteignent l'orgasme dans 90% de leurs rapports sexuels.
Pour résoudre ces problèmes, on vend aux femmes des médicaments discutables,
des crèmes de testostérone...
même des injections génitales non testées.
On ne peut pas arranger la sexualité féminine avec une pilule.
C'est parce qu'elle n'est pas détraquée,
mais incomprise.
Notre culture a une vision biaisée et médicalement incorrecte
de la sexualité féminine
qui remonte à des siècles.
Si la moitié des femmes ont un trouble sexuel,
peut-être que notre idée de la sexualité n'est pas appropriée pour les femmes.
Il nous faut mieux comprendre comment les femmes fonctionnent.
Je suis journaliste
et récemment, j'ai écrit un livre
sur l'évolution de notre compréhension de la sexualité féminine.
La sexualité a été définie quand les hommes dominaient la science.
Les hommes scientifiques voyaient le corps féminin
à travers leur prisme biaisé.
Ils auraient pu interroger les femmes sur leur expérience.
Au lieu de cela, ils ont examiné le corps féminin tel un paysage étranger.
Même aujourd'hui, nous débattons de l'existence
de l'éjaculation féminine et du point G
comme si nous parlions d'extraterrestres ou d'OVNI.
« Existent-ils vraiment ? »
(Rires)
Cela s'applique doublement à la sexualité des femmes LGBTQI
qui a été haïe et bannie de façon spécifique.
L'ignorance sur le corps féminin remonte à des siècles.
Elle remonte au début de la médecine moderne.
Retournez au XVIe siècle,
une ère de révolution scientifique en Europe.
Les hommes d'idées remettaient en question les vieux dogmes.
Ils créaient des télescopes pour admirer les étoiles.
Nous réalisions des progrès...
parfois.
Les pères de l'anatomie --
et je dis « pères » car ce n'étaient que des hommes --
fourrageaient entre les jambes des femmes
et essayaient de répertorier ce qu'ils voyaient.
Ils n'étaient pas trop sûrs au sujet du clitoris.
Il semblait n'avoir rien à faire avec le fait de faire des bébés.
L'éminent anatomiste de l'époque a déclaré
que c'était probablement une croissance anormale --
(Rires)
et que toute femme en ayant un était probablement hermaphrodite.
Les choses ont si mal tourné que, parfois,
les parents faisaient couper le clitoris de leur fille
si on l'estimait trop gros.
C'est vrai.
Une chose que nous considérons comme de la mutilation génitale féminine
a été pratiquée en Occident jusqu'au XXe siècle.
Vous devez vous demander :
s'ils étaient si déconcertés par le corps féminin,
pourquoi n'ont-ils pas demandé de l'aide aux femmes ?
Mais vous devez vous dire : « Tout cela, c'est du passé.
Le monde est différent aujourd'hui.
Les femmes ont tout.
Elles ont la pilule contraceptive,
elles ont les sextos, Tinder et le « vajazzling ».
(Rires)
Les choses sont forcément mieux aujourd'hui.
Mais l'ignorance médicale sur le corps des femmes continue.
Combien d'entre vous reconnaissent ceci ?
C'est la structure entière du clitoris.
Nous voyons le clitoris comme cette protubérance de la taille d'un pois
mais il s'étend profondément dans le corps.
La plupart se trouve sous la peau.
Il contient presque autant de tissu érectile que le pénis.
C'est beau, n'est-ce pas ?
Il ressemble un peu à un cygne.
(Rires)
Cette sculpture est d'une artiste appelée Sophia Wallace
et faisait partie de son projet « Clitorétisation ».
(Rires)
Il nous faut plus de « clitorétisation »
et c'est vrai, si l'on considère que cette structure
n'a été modélisée entièrement en 3D par des chercheurs qu'en 2009.
C'était après que nous avons fini de séquencer entièrement le génome humain.
(Rires)
Cette ignorance a de réelles conséquences.
Dans un journal médical en 2005,
le Dr Helen O'Connell, une urologue,
a alerté ses collègues sur le fait que cette structure n'était nulle part
dans les journaux médicaux principaux --
dans des manuels tels que « Gray's Anatomy ».
Cela pourrait avoir de graves conséquences en chirurgie.
Considérez cela.
Messieurs :
imaginez que vous risquiez de perdre votre pénis
parce que les médecins n'étaient pas sûrs d'où il était
ou de ce à quoi il ressemblait.
Il n'est pas surprenant
que beaucoup de femmes ne soient pas sûres de leur anatomie génitale non plus.
Impossible de leur en vouloir.
Le clitoris manque souvent sur les diagrammes d'éducation sexuelle.
Les femmes sentent que leur culture perçoit leur corps
au mieux avec une certaine confusion,
au pire avec mépris et dégoût.
Beaucoup de femmes voient encore leurs propres organes génitaux
comme impropres ou inadaptés.
Elles comparent de plus en plus leur vulve
à celles, élégantes et petites, qu'elles voient dans la pornographie.
C'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles la labioplastie monte en flèche
parmi les femmes et les adolescentes.
Certains ont l'impression que tout ceci n'est qu'une question triviale.
Pendant que j'écrivais mon livre, à un dîner, quelqu'un m'a dit :
« La sexualité n'est-elle pas un problème du monde développé ?
Les femmes n'ont-elles pas des problèmes plus graves à travers le monde ? »
Bien sûr que si.
Mais je pense que le réflexe de trivialisation du sexe
fait partie de notre problème.
Nous vivons dans une culture qui semble obsédée par le sexe.
Nous y avons recours pour vendre de tout.
Pour les femmes, avoir l'air sexy
est présenté comme l'une des choses les plus importantes à faire.
Mais nous dénigrons le sexe.
Nous le réduisons à une triste ombre de ce qu'il est vraiment.
Le sexe est plus qu'un acte.
J'ai parlé avec le Dr Lori Brotto,
une psychologue qui traite les troubles sexuels chez les femmes,
y compris les survivantes d'un traumatisme.
Elle dit que les centaines de femmes qu'elle voit
ont toutes tendance à répéter la même chose.
Elles disent : « Je ne me sens pas entière. »
Elles ont l'impression d'avoir perdu une connexion
avec leur partenaire et elles-mêmes.
Qu'est-ce que le sexe ?
Nous avons traditionnellement défini l'acte sexuel
comme un processus linéaire, tendant vers un but.
C'est quelque chose qui commence par du désir,
continue avec d'abondantes caresses
et finit par un dénouement heureux.
Sauf que beaucoup de femmes ne le vivent pas ainsi.
Pour elles, c'est moins linéaire et plus circulaire.
Voici un nouveau modèle de l'excitation et du désir féminins
établi par le Dr Rosemary Basson.
Il dit de nombreuses choses,
y compris que les femmes peuvent démarrer une relation
pour de nombreuses raisons
qui ne sont pas du désir,
telle que de la curiosité.
Elles peuvent terminer un orgasme ou de multiples orgasmes,
ou de la satisfaction sans aucun orgasme.
Toutes les options sont normales.
Certains commencent à défendre une définition plus riche de la sexualité.
Que vous vous identifiez comme homme, femme ou d'aucun des genres,
avec le sexe, il est question de notre relation aux sens.
Il s'agit de ralentir,
d'écouter le corps,
d'être dans l'instant présent.
Il s'agit de notre santé et de notre bien-être tout entiers.
Autrement dit,
la vraie ampleur du sexe n'est pas profane,
elle est sacrée.
C'est une des raisons pour lesquelles les femmes redéfinissent leur sexualité.
Elles demandent : « Qu'est-ce que le sexe pour moi ? »
Elles expérimentent des pratiques où il est moins question d'un heureux dénouement
et plus de se sentir entière.
Elles essayent des cours de sexe spirituel,
des ateliers de masturbation --
même tourner leur propre porno
qui célèbre la diversité de vrais corps.
Pour quiconque ayant encore l'impression que c'est un sujet trivial,
considérez ceci :
comprendre votre corps est crucial à la large question
que sont l'éducation sexuelle et le consentement.
En sachant profondément, intimement quel genre de toucher fait du bien,
quelle pression, quelle vitesse, quel contexte,
vous pouvez mieux savoir quel genre de toucher est inapproprié
et avoir la confiance en vous pour l'exprimer.
Il ne s'agit pas que les femmes aient plus ou de meilleures relations sexuelles.
Il s'agit de s'assurer que les femmes aient autant d'orgasmes que les hommes.
Il s'agit de vous accepter, vous et votre expérience unique.
Il s'agit d'avoir une expertise au sujet de votre corps.
Il s'agit de définir vous-même le plaisir et la satisfaction.
Et si vous êtes plus heureux en n'ayant pas de relations sexuelles,
c'est également parfait.
Si nous définissions le sexe comme une partie de notre santé et bien-être,
alors autonomiser les femmes et les filles à le conquérir
est une étape cruciale vers l'égalité.
Et je pense que ce serait un monde meilleur non seulement pour les femmes,
mais pour tout le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)